kerry is struggling to find a way out of
her spiraling debt she owes 20 000
pounds and counting i'm paying it bit by
bit i don't know
i'll probably be dead before it finishes
so
why what can i do
kerry works two days a week as a health
care assistant but even with universal
credit can't get by it's all too much
i'm not a lazy person
i work very hard
it's tough
it's very tough
these days food banks are offering more
than just something to eat as
increasingly people come to them with
money worries
this one in the london borough of
kingston is run by the trussell trust
which has revealed the most common form
of debt now is to the government almost
half of the people they support have
deductions for things like council tax
arrears taken from their benefits
they think they're managing but as
interest rates go up as costs of food
and cost of living go up i think we're
going to find debt just becomes more and
more of an issue
the charity the joseph rowntree
foundation surveyed low-income
households that's those in the bottom 40
it found 4.6 million are behind on at
least one bill in seven months personal
borrowing has more than doubled and 1.3
million households have used credit to
cover essentials such as food
this pawn brokers which only takes
luxury items told us they've seen an
upturn in people trying to raise cash
selling whatever they can
we certainly are seeing more inquiries
coming through from our website and
emails for people inquiring a revered
offer alone against electronical items
or
mobile phones predominantly because i
think that's something a lot of people
do have to hand
the government says it's put in place a
package of support to help with rising
costs but more and more people face a
future owing money they don't have east
holland sky news